all right coming up we got james over in
baltimore land of real seafood james how
are you i'm good how are you doing today
oh we're focused and not finished my
friend i what's your question for us
yeah so like the previous caller i am
also active duty military
um my south is an optometry technician
um currently we make about i'd say
roughly around
six grand a month combined
and my wife has 47 000 in student loan
debt
okay we recently just paid off our
second vehicle i just made a payment
with our tax return that came in um and
i'm just trying to see if i'm taking the
right approach to paying this
student loan debt off currently my wife
solely works to put her entire paycheck
towards the student loans
wow and so i'm just wondering if
while these loans are in forbearance
currently with the current situation the
pandemic
if it's worth um paying the loans off
or building up our emergency fund
because currently we have nothing in
savings
payday loans off man pay the loans off
and i'm gonna tell you why and i try not
to be so aggressive when i hear this
when i hear people say this
but they're in forbearance this means
that they're not racking up interest
right now all right
and so for you what i'm saying is you
want to go in ahead and take advantage
of this like i'm trying to figure out
how to get all of these student loans
knocked out before the interest is
activated
uh again and so with the way the
government is looking right now
it may be a little bit of time you know
but i'm saying take advantage of this i
get it you want to have a savings
account and we want you to have
a fully funded emergency fund but i want
you to be debt free
before you have a fully funded emergency
fund because what you're doing is yes
you're going to put
more money into the savings but long
term you're going to spend
more money into debt that you didn't
have to do
because you was trying to save money so
what i'm saying save yourself true money
by paying off all these student loans
which is 47
000 thank you so much for your service
but i promise
you uh when you pay these student loans
off uh my brother
i promise you you'll thank yourself down
the road now
um now yo y'all listening i mean he
ain't the only one hogan who's
asking that question no not at all i
mean this is a question that you get all
the time
me and dave get i get on my show well
why pay
why pay when i don't i don't have to pay
right now well
you do have to pay if you want to save
money like that's how i look at it
i have to save money i have to change my
future
so i have to pay these student loans off
so i can get
my life back and start focusing on the
future
not worrying about my past no you're
absolutely right and james i would tell
you
you know my friend you want to get a
thousand dollars and have that as just a
starter emergency fund
and then that way if something happens
car repair truck repair
whatever you've got money you can reach
and not have to utilize debt
but anthony's right you need to attack
this debt with a vengeance
uh and delete it and get out of your
life anthony this brings up something
else
what's that we'll have to go here
because people are having their ears
tickled
out there hearing about loan forgiveness
yeah hearing about how the government is
going to save the day
they're going to roll through on the on
the little horse
with the with the student loan fairy and
they're gonna sprinkle dust on people's
student loans and forgive it
yeah you know hogan man
and i'm trying to be sensitive when i
say this because
you know and this is what i study you
know right now i
studies are showing as of today that the
student loan forgiveness program
is not working nearly 85 of the people
are
being declined um i think a higher
number came out here recently today
but the government is talking me and
dave talking about this um earlier this
week
that the government is there there
probably will be something in the future
but we don't know
so for me my thing is because we can't
say yes or no
we're sticking with the no we're going
to take care of our responsibilities
and if it comes then take advantage of
it but as of right now
past experiences are showing us the
government will not forgive the student
loans right well and they're definitely
going to do it to the level that people
are expecting no
like i've heard 10 grand yeah but here's
the thing have you heard this
if they do this they're talking about a
community service component
exactly well i'm paying the 10 grand you
ain't going to make me sir
but how long and what what are you going
to have to do so
my point is is for people out there i'm
with you anthony
i don't want you to have fake hope in a
false plan right
let me say it again i don't want you to
have fake hope and a false plan
i want you to deal with the known right
and so you know you having the mindset
of you digging your way out of debt i
know the moratorium on student loans is
through now
september yes uh and so you know you not
being on hold because here's my fear ayo
people that have gone without paying it
yep and you already know what happens
with people if you're not on a budget
come on now all of a sudden in september
you're going to be like
you're going to hear that knock yes that
this payment is now active again yes yes
yes yes yes and here's here's the thing
logan
and correct me if you if you disagree i
we're not saying that we we don't have a
problem that we need to fix
but the problem is not forgiven the
problem is stopping it from even
happening
so i think when people hear us like oh
dave and anthony is just don't they're
not no no what we're saying is okay yes
this is a problem
let's fix it but i can't fix the leak if
i don't fix what's causing the leak okay
so i can't stop the water from dripping
if i don't fix the hole that's inside of
it so for me it's like let's
stop the student loan program or let's
put a cap on it
let's do something because if we forgive
like what they're talking about the ten
thousand dollars would be close to about
uh 600 billion dollars we still have 1.1
trillion dollars in student loan debt
that is still a major crisis
and will we will be back to 1.7 in the
next few years
so what i'm saying is we're going to be
back well let's pause over here
let's go to the front end and fix the
issue so
my kids your kids our great great
grandkids
do not have this issue going into the
future yeah
no i i agree i mean it is certainly a
massive issue
and you know financially as you start to
look at it impacting 44 million
americans
yeah with student loan debt and you know
the thing that i get riled up about is
that you know we got young people
walking into financial aid offices
signing documents they don't understand
for payments they can't afford
zero can't afford it and so now you
start off life
in the hole and behind